WE’LL BRING IT TO YOU LIVE.
SANDRA.
>> Sandra: THANK YOU, TRACE, A
NEW WEEKLY JOBS REPORT IS OUT
THIS MORNING SHOWING 836,000
AMERICANS FILED FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS LAST WEEK.
THAT IS A BIG NUMBER BUT IT IS
LESS THAN WHAT WAS PREDICTED BY
ANALYSTS AND IT IS AN
IMPROVEMENT FROM THE PREVIOUS
WEEK.
THE DOW IS REACTING OPENING
HIGHER THIS MORNING AS WE HEAD
INTO THE FINAL QUARTER OF 2020.
OCTOBER 1 HERE WE GO.
DOW UP 165 POINTS.
LET’S BRING IN THE FORMER OBAMA
COUNCIL CHAIRMAN AND A
PROFESSOR AT HARVARD.
APPRECIATE HAVING YOU ON THE
PROGRAM AND YOU BRING A UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE.
FIRST TO THAT NEW NUMBER ON THE
ECONOMY.
WHAT DOES IT TELL US, 836,000
FILED FOR UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS
LAST WEEK.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THAT IS NOW
THE LOWEST THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
SINCE THE PANDEMIC STRUCK THE
ECONOMY BACK IN MARCH.
>> YEAH, THAT’S A LOT BETTER
THAN WE WERE IN MARCH.
IT IS ALSO VERY HIGH RELATIVE
TO ANYTHING WE EVER SAW BEFORE
MARCH.
THIS IS A NUMBER YOU WOULD
NORMALLY SEE IN A PRETTY BAD
RECESSION.
SO A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE STILL
LOSING JOBS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE STILL
GAINING JOBS, TOO.
THE ECONOMY IS JUST VERY
TURBULENT RIGHT NOW.
>> Sandra: A CONVERSATION THAT
YOU AND I HAD BACK IN APRIL AND
MAY.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT YOU
MEETING WITH I BELIEVE A ZOOM
MEETING BIPARTISAN BUSINESS
LEADERS.
YOU SUGGESTED THAT WE ARE GOING
TO COME SO SHARPLY OUT OF THE
ECONOMIC DEPRESSION FROM THIS
PANDEMIC THAT IT IS GOING TO
BENEFIT DONALD TRUMP NEAR
ELECTION DAY.
BASED ON THE NUMBER WE JUST PUT
UP ON THE SCREEN BETTER THAN
EXPECTED CERTAINLY SHOWING SOME
PROMISING SIGNS OF A RECOVERY,
DO YOU STILL HOLD THAT THEORY,
THAT THE ECONOMY IS RECOVERING
SO SHARPLY IT WILL BENEFIT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN THE ELECTION?
>> YEAH.
MY VIEW IS THAT THE ECONOMY
WOULD RECOVER VERY SHARPLY BUT
THE RECOVERY WOULDN’T GET ALL
THE WAY THERE.
SO ON ELECTION DAY DONALD TRUMP
WILL BE ABLE TO SAY LOOK AT THE
MILLIONS OF JOBS CREATED AND
JOE BIDEN WILL BE ABLE TO SAY
LOOK, THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS
8% OR WHATEVER TOMORROW.
BOTH SIDES HAVE A GOOD ARGUMENT.
THAT IS PROBABLY WHY NO ONE IS
VOTING OVERLY ON THE ECONOMY
NOW AND THERE ARE SO MANY OTHER
ISSUES.
>> Sandra: THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN,
WHITE HOUSE CAN MAKE THE CASE,
THIS IS A PANDEMIC AND THIS IS
VERY UNUSUAL HISTORIC
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR OUR ECONOMY.
IT IS IMPORTANT, ISN’T IT, TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT WHERE THE
ECONOMY WAS BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
HIT.
PRE-PANDEMIC UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION 5 1/2 MILLION
JOBS WERE ADDED.
WE GO BACK TO THE OBAMA ECONOMY
1.2 MILLION JOBS ADDED IN
OBAMA’S FIRST TERM IN OFFICE.
BY COMPARISON ISN’T PRESIDENT
TRUMP DOING BETTER ON THE
ECONOMY THAN THE OBAMA YEARS?
>> THAT’S A PRETTY ABSURD
COMPARISON WHEN THERE WERE
800,000 JOBS LOST IN FEBRUARY
OF 2009.
I’M NOT SURE THAT WAS BARACK
OBAMA’S FAULT.
>> Sandra: YOU COMPARING THE
PANDEMIC SO I THOUGHT IT WAS
FAIR.
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK IT IS A
LITTLE SILLY TO PLAY THESE
GAMES.
SO MUCH OF WHAT GOES ON IN THE
ECONOMY IS ABOUT AMERICAN
BUSINESSES AND AMERICAN WORKERS.
>> Sandra: FAIR POINT.
NO GAMES, THOSE ARE DATA POINTS.
TO THAT POINT -- TO THAT POINT
JOE BIDEN IS SUGGESTING RAISING
THE CORPORATE TAX RATE.
HOW DOES THAT AFFECT AN ECONOMY
ESPECIALLY AT A TIME IF HE
BECOMES PRESIDENT IN NOVEMBER
OR IS ELECTED IN NOVEMBER, HOW
DOES THAT HELP US RECOVER FROM
THIS ECONOMIC HIT THAT WE’VE
TAKEN?
>> IF YOU LOOK SOME OF THE
MAJOR INVESTMENT BANKS, GOLDMAN
SACHS TOOK A LOOK AT THE BIDEN
ECONOMIC PLAN AND SAID IT WOULD
RAISE ECONOMIC GROWTH OVER THE
NEXT FEW YEARS.
IT WOULD DO MORE TO STIMULATE
THE ECONOMY.
OVERALL THE TAX PLAN WOULD BE
TAX COLLECTION TO WHERE THEY
WERE UNDER PRESIDENT CLINTON.
THE ECONOMY DID PERFECTLY FINE
THEN.
I’M NOT WORRIED ABOUT HIS TAX
PLAN AND I LIKE HIS OVERALL
ECONOMIC PLAN.
>> Sandra: MORE SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT THE CORPORATE TAX RATE IN
A SECOND.
BUT YOU LOOK AGAIN PRE-PANDEMIC
TRUMP ECONOMY YOU HAD THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IN FEBRUARY
DIPPED TO 3.5% IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT IS HARD TO MAKE THE CASE
THAT THIS PRESIDENT HASN’T BEEN
GOOD FOR THE ECONOMY.
YOU HAVE BUSINESSES THAT FEEL
THAT THEY WERE IN A VERY
BUSINESS-FRIENDLY ENVIRONMENT.
DOES JOE BIDEN’S PLAN MAKE OR
RESULT IN A BUSINESS-FRIENDLY
ENVIRONMENT?
I GO BACK TO MY QUESTION ABOUT
THE CORPORATE TAX RATE.
>> THE CORPORATE TAX PLAN
PASSED THE ADMINISTRATION
PROMISED WE WOULD GET TO 3%
ECONOMIC GROWTH.
WE FELL WAY SHORT OF THAT FOR
THE NEXT TWO YEARS AFTER IT,
SANDRA.
WHY ARE YOU LOWERING THE BAR,
LOWERING THE STANDARDS?
I HEARD PEOPLE ON YOUR CHANNEL
OVER AND OVER AGAIN TALKING
ABOUT 3% GROWTH, 3% GROWTH.
HE NEVER GOT IT.
HE NEVER GOT CLOSE TO IT.
HE HAD GROWTH RATES LOWER THAN
WE SAW UNDER THE LAST FOUR
YEARS OF PRESIDENT OBAMA.
SO I DON’T THINK THERE WAS ANY
TYPE OF -- THE ECONOMY IS
PERFECTLY GOOD BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC.
GRANT YOU THAT.
AFTER THAT NOTHING MIRACULOUS
OR SPECIAL.
DIDN’T IMPROVE.
>> Sandra: WHAT KIND OF GROWTH
ARE YOU FORECASTING FOR A
POTENTIAL BIDEN ADMINISTRATION?
I THINK WE’LL SEE A GROWTH RATE
OF AROUND 2% AND I THINK WE
WOULD SEE A GROWTH RATE OF
AROUND 2% IF TRUMP GOT A SECOND
TERM BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT OF
DEMOGRAPHIC CHALLENGES AS
WORKERS ARE GETTING OLDER AND
THAT’S USE IS A FACT THAT I
THINK WE SHOULD ACCEPT THE
REALITY OF.
>> Sandra: I DIDN’T GET TO ANY